hallo mein name ist luca und ich zeig
euch heute eine sehr sehr geile clash of
clients modifikation in minecraft wir
befinden uns hier in der clash of plants
map die guter freund vor das heißt guter
freund und bekannte eigentlich evans
heißt der beziehungsweise einfach nick
und ich hab euch einfach mal den link zu
der map in die beschreibung gepackt
allerdings was ich bisher nutze
brennstoff plans in bezug auf minecraft
vorgestellter waren irgendwelche maps
oder verschiedene möglichkeiten um
häuser zu bauen was ich euch allerdings
heute zeigen möchte ist beim schleim
hast du schon was ich euch heute zeigen
möchte ist ein reiz bringt hier wieder
die das hatten wir letzte mal auch das
einfach die halbe map abgebrannt ist man
nick egal wir machen was ihr euch heute
zeigen möchte ist hier von und zwar beim
ich ja nie mit skills wie wird das
ausgesprochen dort finden wir mehrere
item von spawn arabellion giant gabriel
m und hock ritter und das sind diese gar
oak ridge a hawk rider in ordnung lokal
das sind quasi die einzigen sachen die
bisher hinzugefügt wurden und die mod
ist auch gar nicht mal so alt also ich
glaube die physiker zwei monate draus
oder so lass mich nicht mögen keine
ahnung jedenfalls haben diese items alle
eine gewisse bedeutung und zwar fangen
einfach mal an bevor ich noch länger um
lover wir haben hier sportlich den
hinsetzte seht ihr schon es pont ein
bogenschütze da ich allerdings in dieser
map keine per missions habe um irgend
etwas umzustellen also um mich selbst in
den gamer zu bringen werde ich euch das
ganze jetzt hier erst mal ganz gut
zeigen also das ist hier der archer und
bleiben wir kurz eine andere welt dann
zeige ich euch wie die ganzen leute auf
mich reagieren wenn ich im game mode 0
bin und das ist nicht so schön also am
besten dran bleiben noch kurz das ist
der archer megacool design also wirklich
mit den augen sogar augenbrauen sind
davon seht ihr die das sind einfach
augenbrauen alter des übels gras
megageil design sie hat sogar tillys
glaube ich hey kollege bleiben ganz klar
von der seite ja da sind ihre brüste sie
hat halt ein bogen der handel hat auch
schon geil gepixelten ich hör auf mit
ihr zu sagen dass sie unglaublich gut
designt ist also wenn
weiter hier ist die dealerin schülerin
ist ja eine die man selber haben kann
wenn kleinstadt plant man sich selber
mitnehmen kann die kann man einsetzen um
die eigenen truppen zu heilen und das
ist ihnen die schwebt dann immer über
den wie ein auftippen seht ihr das auch
tippen am start von den hierin brauche
ich bzw braucht ich damals mal richtig
viele weil meine leute waren immer sehr
anfällig für angriffe aber naja das ist
auf jeden fall die kielerin die schwebt
über den da gibt allerdings von buck
servus derart sharjah poster hingelaufen
da gibt es manchmal so ein bug dass die
einfach im boden stecken bleibt aber
meines derzeit noch ganz bugfrei das
nächste was wir haben ist der bavarian
und der sieht er aus wie hierhin stein
mit einem core bis die normale menschen
sind so ein mensch mit mit bisschen
muskeln und der bavarian ist einfach so
muskeln mit bisschen mensch so sieht der
in etwa warum läufst du den ganzen weg
zu kleine messe also der ist schon krass
muss gelöst da meinten die auch dass die
das waren noch mal dran arbeiten werden
weil er wirkliche sieht einfach ein
außer der schulter bestehen aber dass
auf jeden fall der bavarian dann haben
wir noch den job das ist quasi der
bavarian groß also derzeit ist er bewegt
sich ganz langsam fort aber dafür sehr
viel leben und kann noch sehr viel
kaputt machen sage ich mal kostet auch
dementsprechend fielen clash of plants
also das ist der giant und was die halt
da noch berichtigen wollen sind die
augen also die sind aber doch so ein
bisschen komisch dann haben wir noch den
goblin der ehrlich gesagt mir rat ein
bisschen angst macht
die goblins sind so ein kleines volk die
können einfach gold und elixiere die
konzentriert sich direkt auf die ganzen
minen und so weiter apropos mehrere
spender zu regnen steht apropos minen
die wurden jetzt noch nicht hinzugefügt
das sollte allerdings auch noch kommen
wir machen schnell weiter mit dem golem
der golem ist der hier kann ich euch
nicht zu sagen was der gemacht und auch
nicht was der hog rider genau macht weil
ich so noch und weiten noch nicht war in
clash of plants bevor ich sie
installiert habe die habe ich noch nicht
herausfinden können aber die sind auch
im spiel vorhanden sehen auch so ein
bisschen sehr muskulös und aus als
würden sie nur aus links und sein hammer
schwebt irgendwie in der luft das sind
bisher alle sachen die derzeit
hinzugefügt wurden dazu jetzt dauerhaft
geupdatet also bekomme ich noch - was
alles dazu erst der hog rider der golem
der gablenberger giant der bavarian der
hela und der archer das sind die ganzen
mops team zugefügt wurden und was diese
mops anstellen werde ich euch jetzt
einfach mal kurz zeigen so ich habe
jetzt einfach mal eine komplette rüstung
hier geholt da seht ihr es auch nein ich
will nicht sport fast nicht mehr bei
youtube bleiben ihr seht schon ich habe
eine komplette rüstung an und habe
dementsprechend dazu auch noch goldene
apples mein deutsches wieder komplett am
ende hieß wollen einfach mal den archer
und ihr seht schon wenn ich jetzt in den
game mode 0 greift nämlich auf
dementsprechend direkt an wenn er mich
sieht das tut weh und ihr seht schon ich
habe tausend und jetzt meine herzen
gehen gerade extrem schwer und obwohl
ich eine komplette diamant russland habe
das muss man sich mal geben ich habe
eine komplette diamant rüstung an
und sie hat mich durch die pfeile und
des bösen auf zweieinhalb
heruntergebracht übels krass geht's
eigentlich klar von der belichtung oder
denkt ich bin total jesus weil ich so
hell bis also das macht der arzt dann
haben wir hier den lila das habe ich
noch gar nicht mehr ausgetestet ich
denke ja der wird mich einfach heilen
weil er in meiner nähe ist er hat mich
auch gerade mit einer flasche abgeworfen
genau das macht die kielerin ich frage
mich ob die kielerinnen mich jetzt auch
verfolgt wenn ich irgendwo anders sind
hier weil das wäre ganz interessant zu
sehen nein sie bleibt einfach dastehen
weil sie müsste mich ja eigentlich
verfolgen im kampf oder oder
und ja ich habe gerade gesagt im kampf
und zwar diese modifikation multiplayer
tauglich das heißt ihr könnt euch das
download und euer kumpel und ihr könnt
dann gegeneinander kämpfen tragen mega
cool finde ich echt klasse dann haben
wir hier ich baue jetzt erstmal auf den
bavarian steht auch schon der greift
nicht direkt an der macht erstmal nicht
so viel schaden aber ihr seht schon der
greift dann halt viel schneller an als
der hartschaum heute in einen burn jetzt
ist es ja gerade auch am ruckeln und ein
halt die ganze zeit und macht dann
dementsprechend damit dann auch schaden
ich muss jetzt meinen kurzum bringen
soll der hatte gegen meine ich auch 20
leben also das war der bavarian ich erst
mal eben noch mal kurz und golden apple
damit ich hier wieder top aufleben bin
dann kann ich euch meinen noch den
dreien zeigen die attackiert mich auch
direkt dass sie dir auf der macht
allerdings okay ich habe jetzt natürlich
gerade noch die regeneration effekte
drin das stimmt natürlich auch
interessante kann mich jetzt nicht
attackieren wenn ich hier doch doch kann
aber okay alles gleich dachte gerade
kabinett erklären welche unter dem baum
stehe aber alles schillig ich verliere
halt echt keinen kein leben oder habe
ich noch ich habe die regeneration okay
die regeneration ist genau jetzt weg das
heißt leider mich jetzt angreift bekomme
ich da irgendeinen schaden ich bitte
auch gemeiner herzen gehen runter der
giant hat noch relativ wenig leben dafür
dass er wirklich so ein großer models
sag ich mal das wird auch im video
remmers bemängelt dass das noch
berichtigt wird sage ich mal so ich
konnte ihn jetzt noch relativ schnell
töten aber wir machen direkt weiter mit
dem goblin und zwar kann ich einfach mal
den ich habe den goblin schon dahin
gesetzt der goblin kann mich auch töten
ganz klar also er hat auch kraft
allerdings natürlich nicht so viel wie
in berlin oder reparieren oder wie in
aschau oder so weil der goblin ist halt
mehr dafür ausgelegt wirklich im kampf
direkt aufs gold zugehen wenn es denn
hinzugefügt wird
dann haben wir hier noch den golem da
weiß ich selber nicht ganz genau was er
macht ob es auch ganz schön kräftig
nennen wenn wir ihnen das mal töten auch
noch relativ schnell tot und wenn wir
hier den hock ritscher haben alle ok der
der ist echt stark erst sehr sehr stark
der rock ridge er hat mich tatsächlich
runtergebracht anzeiger nochmal ganz
gezielt in artern was der halo siehst
mich oder er bringt mich halt direkt
impulsen level runter da habe ich ihn
oft und jetzt bin ich auf einem herz die
teile sind echtstart das ist quasi alles
was die modifikation zu hinzufügt also
diese ganzen verschiedenen websites
quasi ich gehe noch mal kurz in game und
1 und euch nochmal zu zeigen also geht
hier in diesem michael wird erwartet ob
und dann sehen wir hier diese sieben
verschiedenen mops hinzugefügt wurden
die einfach
allein für das komplette motten modeling
von diesem mob sollte man eigentlich
schon zehn trilliarden daumen hoch geben
für diese modifikation dies einfach so
krass also man sollte einfach mal schöne
grüße da lassen ihr findet links zu der
mord und zu der ersten map die ich von
mir gezeigt habe und in der beschreibung
check das auf jeden fall aus wenn euch
das video gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen ich werde ich
auf jeden fall auf marktplätzen
standhalten also wenn da etwas neues
rauskommen mit neuen buden und neuen
mops wenn ich darüber dementsprechen
wieder ein video machen oder das auf
twitter posten oder so ja